[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sweeties a piece how you guys doing
guess what we're going we're going
downtown but I got this sign what's the
sign Eddie well you can see it right
here says why don't you ask me about
Islam are you going to old Islamophobes
the haters are getting paid to bash
Islam why don't you come to the Muslims
let me ask my friend bro how you feeling
my friend yeah slow McLagan what I'm
fine
so what kind of questions do you expect
people to ask you basically but all the
media going doing the rounds with
Islamophobic matter and content a lot of
people they fear Islam the thing Islam
is a religion of hate mongers it's the
Muslim community that is responsible for
the problems so the best way is wipe out
Islam and the world will be in peace and
there's something very dangerous people
ask about jihad about terrorism so these
are the things that really need to be
addressed that's so important and what
it says on the sides sciences why don't
you ask me why I talk about that how
important is it that you you come to the
Muslims to learn it was in the skull and
have a healthy dialogue come to the mass
make the human connection true very true
I mean when you're going to ask somebody
who is already not believing in Islam
hating Islam the information you are
going to get is a wrong information and
these hate mongers against Islam I call
them the hate mongers against Islam
these people they are actually
delivering stuff that is creating more
problems on earth it's not Islam it's
not the common Muslim who is doing the
problems it's these people who are doing
all the problems yes
I agree there may be some Muslims are
not right and they need to be corrected
we are there to correct them we need
your support and you need our support to
correct these people
and these people are not just in the
Muslim community they are there in every
community and every community needs to
correct their own people and people who
are the mainstream communities they need
to coordinate with each other cooperate
with each other and connect these people
so stay tuned we're gonna be asking the
common folk their questions ask us ask
us what you want to know and we're happy
to answer stay tuned so I'm like home
how you guys doing so we're here and we
encourage people to come to us and ask
that's why we have the sign here with
why don't you ask me about Islam we love
for people to engage with us so many
misconceptions and to get through that
we got our first portion err how you
doing my friend this accept this Islam
all right so he just says some Arabic of
hundun la means I'll praise the god to
the Creator many people think we worship
a different God but the same God that
Jesus worship Abraham Moses they all
submitted to the Creator not to creation
we love Jesus answer those questions you
might have they need to be filtered out
and we all know that not because they
wanted to leave their home
you too thank you very much
people are asking questions why don't
you ask a Muslim and if you don't get to
ask us here today you can call us at
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
1-866-448-4843
what do you think yeah that's because if
I want to learn America to go to China
or ask a Chinese about what is every
color that religion about what is
America when I know they are going to
speak against America so I'm going to
come to America to ask an American what
is America so I expect the non-muslims
to come to the Muslims and ask therefore
is Islam the radicals I don't go to the
druggist and the rapist to ask what is
America I go to the knowledgable people
to ask what is America
Hey
tell me about Islam yeah I mean it's the
way of life where it demands that a man
or a woman should submit their will to
the will of the creator smart like that
yes
and the Muslim is defined as a person
who willfully submits himself to God
smart
how do you feel about
murdering infidels thing you got art
pass on them episode Old Testament
[ __ ] castle basically what I feel is
what's happening in the name of religion
yeah when it it's violence in the name
of religion when unauthorized people
take up religion in their own hands it's
like a common man taking up the law in
their own hands
right and that's very wrong it shouldn't
be done religion to talk about more and
Islam also as a political system talks
about war but it does not authorize a
common man on the road to pick up arms
and kill infidels or disbelievers
absolutely not if I kill everybody
Who am I going to cut me the bomb
forward is you mentioned his word
infidel I mean yeah is about when he
captured Makkah he did not kill anybody
and he in fact aside it's a day of
giving forgiveness and mercy to the
people and then we have what I always
tell
unfortunately it's all media that's
playing the game whoopee not all the
media people like you are needed to come
up and different humanity well I like
like the way that you are interpreting
in Islam it's very peaceful and loving
it's good I mean I I agree that I would
not be a hypocrite
to say that Islam doesn't talk about
warts some of us talk about warts but it
looks for example when you read surah
number 60 I had number eight of the
Quran Allah says those who do not fight
with you then be good to them be kind to
them and Allah does not prevent you from
being kind towards those
we don't find you it's about those
people who are fighting it suppose
somebody attacks if somebody attacks you
have all the right to sell different and
but unfortunately if somebody is doing
something wrong it's this problem for
example Mercedes is one of the best cars
BMW is one of the best cars but if they
made accident then we are going to
verify whether the person behind the
steering and a license or not if he was
driving without a license
then the problem is not with the car but
it's with the driver so it's like these
Muslims who are doing something without
the license to do it whether they're
extremist yeah Christian thank you so
much thank you we're with our friends
we're showing them our sign this is a
sign we had why don't you ask me about
it about Islam instead of going to
people outside of Islam come to the
Muslims to learn about as long as it
makes sense Gregory what do you think
that's a good point huh because there's
so many people talking about Islam you
got some people who do things opposite
to Islam what would says radicals it's a
very fringe small element but you got
these people going to them as if they
represent Islam now that's crazy but
they forgetting about American hero
Muhammad Ali yeah he was inspired by
Islam and you see all the good he was
doing right so if you guys had to ask
any question said you got a couple
Muslim what would you guys ask anything
anything any questions no
yeah basically
Christians have to respect whose vice
versa
respect is very important we spent
respect each other
respect your thing did you know that
Islam was actually the only
non-christian faith which makes it an
article of faith to believe in love
Jesus that you can get a one-way ticket
to the Hellfire if you deny Jesus if you
spill if you speak ill of him did you
know that you didn't you learned
something already huh is that true or
what yeah yeah absolutely right I mean
we are the only non Christian community
for whom it's an article of faith to
believe and love Jesus as much as we
love and believe in Prophet Muhammad
it's allah assalamu be upon him and no
Muslim is a Muslim if he doesn't believe
and love Jesus Christ may peace be upon
him yeah in fact in the glorious quran
we have a very high rank for jesus
christ i think that is the only
difference between the christian
brothers and sisters and the muslim
community is they considered jesus to be
equal to god or god or the son of god
and we say no he is not God he is not
equal to God is not the sort of God he's
a mighty Messenger of God I mean like
Christians we addressed to his miracles
he say he gave life to the dead but by
God's permission and that is what here
tests in the Bible to that I cast out
devils with the finger of God I cast out
spirits with the help of God so we say
he gave life to the dead by a last
permission he healed those who were born
blind and lepers but by a Las permission
we believe that he was born miraculously
to mother Mary without any male
intervention unfortunately a lot of
Christians do not believe this today but
we Muslims we believe that so I think
you know important thing there's even a
chapter named after his Blessed Mother
in the car yeah so when people you know
because there's a lot of this hate
rhetoric and people are you know
dividing us Americans dividing humanity
with this spewing this hate you follow
me so we try to bridge this gap to show
the commonalities to show the deep you
know love and respect we have for Jesus
and try to clear up many of these
misconceptions false notions that people
have so we invite them to ask the
Muslims so one but go ahead please
please certain Muslims fight in the name
of jihad beautiful quartz did you hear
that why do certain most of the fight
beautiful now we're talking good
question
repeat the question so our viewers can
can hear what he said you know and he
said that why do Muslims fight in the
name of jihad so basically there are
three different aspects to get
understanding for this question
oh I've heard your name brother what's
your name is for purport okay but there
are three basic aspects to this question
put it this way a country has got a
government and a system and that system
has a legal way to fight a war or wage a
war against its enemies am i right yes
so jihad in Islam is actually a concept
that is to be held by the Muslim
government not by individuals or groups
like for example in the aquifer
India has got about 29 states today and
US has got about 50 states tomorrow I
state cannot decide that we are going to
wage war with Canada or Mexico or Brazil
it's an entire system that will decide
that the central government will decide
it so back in India Gujarat cannot
decide we are going to make a war with
Pakistan or China
Ortolan Oregon I decide that it's the
Indian government that will decide that
so similarly the Islamic aspect of jihad
is that the Muslim government will
decide if they have to fight a war it
should be a just war to defend the
Muslim community to define the practices
which are the fundamentals of the
religion of Islam the second aspect to
it is suppose you are attacked then
every law gives you the right to self
defend yourself so that when we do to
self-defend myself to self defend my
property my family that is also doing
jihad in the way of Allah and the third
one unfortunately which today you find a
lot of people discussing about is a few
fringe elements who have taken up the
law in their own hands
and in the name of religion they have
taken up to violence and extremism just
like every other religion has these
elements like back in India we have some
groups which in the name of Hinduism
they do things lady Anderson doesn't
preach back in Myanmar Buddhism was
considered to be a religion of peace and
tolerance but look at what the Buddhists
in Myanmar did but for what the
Buddhists in Myanmar did to the Muslims
they you
blame the whole of the prism or the
teachings of Buddhism similarly when you
come to Crusades of Christianity says
they kill millions of people they kill
millions of Jews there so you can't
bleep I blame Christianity as a whole
you see if you are a Hindu or the KKK
for instance here the Ku Klux Klan of
USA in the name of Christianity what it
does the IRA
the Irish Republican Army it's a
Christian organization the same way like
back in India we have a mythology
whether in Mahabharat am i right yes so
you see Mahabharat was a fight in the
name of religion against the enemies of
God so similarly when you read the Bible
also Jesus says in the Gospel of Matthew
chapter number 10 will stamina for think
not that I have come he says think not
that I have come to spread peace on
earth I have not come to spread peace
but a swerve
so that does not testify that Jesus is a
terrorist or he has come to wage wars
but it means if time comes then we have
to be ready to fight the enemies of the
God so in that sense Islam demands we
are unfortunately some people have miss
practiced it and the mainstream media
like the Fox News they pick up these fin
elements as if to represent them as the
whole of the Muslim community you will
be shocked that the FBI statistics from
the US a it says after September 11 till
date Muslims were involved only in 5% of
the terrorist attacks on American soil
whereas Jews were involved in 6% and you
had more than 42 or 43 percent of the
white supremacists involved in the
attacks and the Latinos attacks were
more than the Muslims doing it on the
American soil
if you check the Europol muslims were
hardly at involved in one or two attacks
in entire Europe between 2013 to 2015
but the media has always been wrongly
projecting and they have been purchasing
a lot of good by exploiting the wrong
information amongst the masses who are
either ignorant about Islam or who are
innocent and they do not have the right
knowledge about Islam so that's the
biggest problem actually I think you you
understood it getting it correlated with
bhagavad-gita and all this yeah so it's
not just Islam that has a concept of war
it's all religions that have a concept
of war it's some people misusing it in
the name of religion you heard about dr.
Robert Pape ok he is from USA and he's
an expert on studying suicide bombing
and he wrote a book dying to win and
it's the central research work for all
the government agencies today whether
it's American army Indian army or
whoever on suicide bombing and in that
book he comes out with a very amazing
discovery he says that more than 50% of
the suicide bombings were committed by
non-muslims not by Muslims and the
maximum number of suicide bombings
committed in the world were committed by
ltte you heard that group no I haven't
le te
is a group of Camel Liberation Tamil
Tigers Elam that's the name of the group
that was fighting in Sri Lanka and most
of the people who were a part of that
group for another 99.99% of the people
involved in that group but those who
would call themselves a Hindus and dying
to win the book it says more than 50% of
the attacks by non-muslims maximum by
LTTE
so unfortunately many people do not know
that and he says that he studied why
people take to suicide bombing and he
says more than ninety percent of the
cases of suicide bombing but not in the
name of religion but it was a reaction
to foreign occupation on their lands
that is this research line it's the
center of a recent book for a lot of
agencies today so the question is the
purpose of life so one is to live to
live life is that right great to live
life and then path I think that to live
life is true for everything that's alive
on this earth yeah is to survive
other things to fall into that up under
that you know good umbrella but I mean
you know you can't get passed back there
we'd have to live you have to survive
sometimes it encompasses a lot of
different things I often make this
example and I ask people to observe the
different things around us for instance
to watch if someone's wearing on their
hand the iPhone iPad that they use the
keys in their pocket I'd usually
challenge people to observe and look
around them and to find anything that
they can see touch feel that doesn't
have a purpose that they're the keys
that they use daily as a purpose the
jacket they wear has a purpose the
shoelaces on their shoes have a purpose
then I usually ask people to also look
at the person who's utilizing these
things and to ask themselves for what
because everything is serving has been
made to serve us in one way or another
is the right someone you make those
things material things to serve us
alright but what about the human being
from what purpose has he or she been
ultimately created for if we come to the
realization that design indicates a
designer and behind this whole mass
universe and everything in it has been
precisely tuned it has all the elements
everything we need to function to
survive but now the human being who's
the most intricate from all these things
what is he created for right what are we
what is our main purpose of its above
and what is your what is your response
to your own question sir
well the the response from the Islamic
view and Islam is simply an Arabic word
which means submission to the will of
God but in the definition of the word
comes the answer is that just like human
beings create things to serve God
Almighty the creator the same creator
who created Jesus Moses Abraham the
Creator who created the Sun and the moon
and everything in this universe he
created the human being to serve in to
worship Him
now that means everything that God loves
God loves that you help those who are
oppressed
God loves that you feed the poor God
love these are means to the ultimate
goal under the umbrella of worship so
everything that God loves and you do it
because a lot of times people will
confuse the means with the ultimate goal
so everything you do that God loves is
an act of worship right and everything
you you stay away from that God has
prohibited out of his ultimate knowledge
and wisdom that's an act of worship so
that is what we believe the ultimate
purpose of life is is to serve God and
to obey Him and by doing everything that
God loves that's an act of worship and
staying away from everything and then
everything is laid out we have in Islam
we have the verbatim Word of God would
be the Quran and it talks about you know
all of the basics of worshiping God
alone that's the first and primary thing
not to set up partners of God to only
worship the Creator
and you see this you'll see like what's
beautiful is that when you when you when
you look at throughout time you see God
out of his love he sent messengers he
didn't leave us in the dark and all of
these messengers they didn't come with
different religions they all came with
the same religion the same way of life
which was submit yourself to the creator
and don't worship the creation that has
always been the same same as Jesus
brought it Abraham brought it no abroad
it and all the other messengers they all
called human beings to defer to to
direct their worship to the one creator
and not to worship a stick of stone a
human being a man a woman a saint the
messenger right
and then they came with guidance you
know how to
nice meeting you my friend alright I got
the card check out check out yeah okay
yeah all right how do you say bye in the
language how do we say bye okay so that
would be that would be the answer to the
questions a worship God and serve God
and one of the things of serving God is
is serving humanity being in the service
of humanity you know this is something
that is the crust knowing that also this
life is a test we're here for a short
amount of time and every human being is
going to be accountable for what they
did in this life right and then at the
end we believe there's a day of judgment
and the final judgment is left to God
and that it wouldn't be it would be on
it's unfair if God didn't send
messengers didn't send guidance and then
from there the wonderful wards a
paradise for the criminals of the world
those people who set up partners with
God those who rejected who the Hitler's
of the world they'll be brought to
account
you know that did you know that over 30
to 40% of the the original I would say
the natives of of America the original
Americans you want to say we're actually
African Americans the Muslims they were
Muslim did you know that Kunta Kinte if
you look if the America
african-americans they look into the
roots you'll see that you know in Africa
you come you have Islam has it so
there's a rich history in Islam very
rich history when you look at like you
ever watch the roots Kunta Kinte you
know he would say Allah he would see
what Collin God and this is because yeah
[Applause]